[Music]
hello everyone how's it going
didn't get my slide clicker out yeah
this is my first time in Singapore it's
yeah it's nice oh this is already going
well if I get an applause for that
that's fantastic it's like I haven't
really looked around yet like I landed
just before the conference so I can't
say I've really experienced it yet but
I'm gonna stay on for a few days
afterwards and you know and have a
proper explore
I brought my partner along with me as
well and I have to say that was a big
mistake a huge mistake because she's
been really looking forward to this trip
right and especially over the last
couple of weeks she's been saying things
like I don't know two weeks till we go
to Singapore one week till we go to
Singapore five days to go four days to
go and I could you could you please not
do that because what I'm hearing right
is five days you only have five days to
finish your talk four days three days
you're still not ready are you said the
worst project manager ever just like
taunting me and how unprepared I am but
then she's brilliant like she knows how
to she knows how to put up with me
because because I stress right I stress
pretty easily I stress about things that
aren't really problems I stress about
things that are really nothing to do
with me and someone posted this picture
on Twitter last week he's holding a
MacBook between two fingers both
concrete's
I have not slept since I saw this
picture I stressed about code like this
right and firstly because there's no
semicolons give me a cheer if you use
semicolons and JavaScript yes good to
hear the rest of you are monsters but
that's not the main thing that stresses
me out late it's because it's adding
stuff to the DOM and then hiding it like
presumably to show it some time later
like on clicker or something and that
stresses me out because it's like
can we be sure that the users not going
to see like a flash of that element
before it's hidden and and I've never
been able to recreate this problem I've
never seen it happen but I you never
know when it comes to race conditions so
I always just swap those lines around
you know just so I can get some sleep
but really there's no race condition
here because the timing of running code
and rendering is always all tightly
defined and mostly deterministic and
that is thanks to the event loop and if
I do a half decent job in the next 30 or
so minutes you'll know why things run in
the order they do and I don't know it
might even make sense but there's no
promises there so web pages have a thing
that we tend to call the main thread
here's the page the mainframe we call it
the main thread because loads of stuff
happens here is where JavaScript happens
it's we're rendering happens it's where
the Dom lives and this means that the
bulk of your stuff on the web has a
deterministic order we don't get
multiple bits of code running at the
same time like trying to edit the same
DOM and giving you a world of horrible
rate conditions but it doesn't mean that
if something on the main thread takes a
long time and by a long time I mean like
200 milliseconds that's a long time in
terms of user interaction then it
becomes really noticeable because it's
blocked loads of other things like it
blocks rendering it blocks interaction
and I think it's difficult for us to
think in this way because as humans we
are extremely multi-threaded like I can
stand here I can wave one hand I can
stand on one leg I can wave the other
leg and all the time I'm speaking I'm
breathing and processing audio and
visual information as humans we don't
really have a main thread we don't
really have things that block unrelated
things I mean we have one and that is
when we sneeze because as you begin to
sneeze just stuff
shuts down you know late and the first
thing you lose is the ability to talk
then you pull a stupid face
if you're driving at this point this is
where you think huh I hope no one dies
at least of all me and then the human
body becomes entirely single-threaded
like you were sneezing nothing else you
can't see here think you can move and
make noises but only in ways the sneeze
wants you to you have no control over
this at all and then it's over right you
essentially wake up and you find out if
your car is still on the road if you
have the same number of limbs you
started with the same number of
passengers you started with right
needless to say we don't want to write
code that is like a sneeze so although
we have this and this main thread' thing
we tend to spawn a whole series of
threads like for networking stuff
encoding and decoding crypto monitoring
input devices but once these threads
have done something that the page needs
to hear about they need to sort of come
back to the main thread to give it that
information and it's the event loop that
orchestrates all of this they take a set
timeout for instance is it badly named
yes are the arguments in the wrong order
I'd say so but have you thought about
how it actually works well let's write a
web standard for it because that's what
I do these days what's that with a set
timeout method when invoked must run the
following steps wait Emmet's
milliseconds invoke callback done but
this isn't quite working because spec
text like this this runs on the same
thread as whatever invokes it and in
this case it's invoked by JavaScript so
this is running on the main thread so if
we say wait 5,000 milliseconds we are
waiting five thousand milliseconds on
Dom the main thread were blocking lots
of other stuff so this spec is very
sneezy right now so we need to change
that and we do this we run the steps in
parallel which is magic spec speak for
get off the main thread or get off this
thread and run this stuff kind of at the
same time as other stuff but we create a
new problem here because now we're
invoking a callback from something other
than the main thread and I mean there's
no way this can really work you would
end up with lots of JavaScript running
in parallel still editing the same DOM
and you'd end up with all of these race
conditions so what
this week you a task and week you were
tasked to get back on to the main thread
at some point and now we're calling
JavaScript on the thread where
JavaScript lives so it all works and
this is a core part of how the browser
works so if you click the mouse like how
does that get from the operating system
into your JavaScript it queues a task
when you face something how did you get
the response into your JavaScript well
accuse a task and you send a message
from a page to a worker once again
accuse a task to do that so the first
part the event loop I want to look at a
task queues and this is the oldest part
of the event loop rather than look at
the spec I for it might be easier to try
and visualize the event loop so here it
is this misses it I hope that clears up
any questions you have actually I really
hope it does because I based the whole
talk around this one diagram so I hope
it works but yeah with without anything
to do the event loop just spins round
and round in a CPU efficient manner
now this visualization is running at a
fraction of a percent of real time and
it's still kind of too fast to really
see what's going on
so let's slow things down a bit when we
queue a task the event loop takes a
detour so that it's miss here this
detail here this is where tasks happen
so at some point the browser says to the
event loop hey I've got a job for you to
do and the event lead was like excellent
ok add it to my to-do list and I'll get
round to it at some point
no problem done what if we do this like
using set timeout we queue two callbacks
that we want to run after one second
1,000 milliseconds well according to the
spec we wrote these two algorithms go
parallel each waits for a thousand
milliseconds and then they need to come
back on to the main thread and they do
that by queuing a task so the browser
says to the event loop hey I've got
something here that wants to do main
thread work in fact I have two things
and it adds each one as a separate to-do
item in the task queue in fact event
loops like sure that's fine I'll get
round to it
so it runs the first callback it goes
around the event loop and runs the
second callback and that's
tasks and it would be pretty simple if
that's all it was but it gets more
complicated when we think about the
render steps and this is what the
browser uses to update what's actually
on the screen the render steps are
another detour and that involves style
calculation this is looking at all of
the CSS that's going on and working out
what applies to each element layout is
in creating a render tree figuring out
where everything is on the page and
where it's positioned and then creating
actual pixel data you know doing the
actual painting so at some point the
browser will say to the event loop hey
you know we need to wait to update
what's on the screen and event loops
like no problem I'll get round to that
next time I go around the event loop now
I don't know about you but I would
consider myself an expert at coding
badly but I can take very simple bits of
JavaScript and create infinite loops out
of them in places I'll eat least expect
but let's take a closer look at what
happens when I do that here's a page
with a gif and some text and a big
button that runs an infinite JavaScript
loop so if I click that button
everything stops the gif has stopped I
can no longer select text the whole tab
has kind of come to a standstill code
for this are simple this is just button
click while true so how do we actually
visualize this well the user clicks the
button so the browser says hey event
loop I've got a task for you event loops
like yep no problem I'm on it but this
task never ends it's running JavaScript
forever a couple of milliseconds later
at the browser says hey event loop like
um we need to update that gif that was
on the page so if you could just render
at your next earliest convenience that
would be fantastic and event loops like
yeah okay I'll get round to that right
after I finish this infinite loop there
I'm busy doing right now then they use a
tries to highlight text and that
involves like hit testing involves
looking at the Dom to see what the text
actually is so the browser says hey I've
got a couple of more items we got to-do
list there and the event looks like are
you having a laugh like do you know how
long it takes to perform an infinite
loop
it's a long time you know there is a
clue in the name so that is why a while
loop blocks rendering and of a page
interaction but this is a good thing in
practice we look again at the code that
I started with I used to worry that this
would result in a flash of content but
it can't write because this script runs
as part of a task and that must run to
completion before the browser can get
back around to the render steps the
event loop guarantees your task will
complete before rendering next happens
it still stresses me out though I'll
always walk these lines around and I see
it in code so a while loop lots
rendering but what about this so this is
a loop but each time we go around a loop
we're using set timeout to queue the
next call well let's find out so very
similar testing before I click the
button and things are still working in
fact it kind of looks like nothing has
changed
but in the background here's what's
happening we queue a task
go around the event loop pick up that
task and we queue another task as a
result and that just keeps happening and
happening until the end of time but as
we've already seen like only one task
can be processed at a time so when it's
process a task is having to go all the
way around the event loop to pick up the
next task so and that means at some
point the browser can say huh we should
update the display for that gif and it
can it can go around and update the
display and that's why a set timeout
loop is not render blocking but if you
want to run code that has anything to do
with rendering a task is really the
wrong place to do it because a task is
on the opposite side of the world to all
of the rendering stuff as far as the
event loop is concerned what we want to
do is we want to run code in the render
steps I want to run code here and the
browser lets us do that lets us do that
using requestanimationframe another
another badly named function I think but
it's it's really good for this purpose
rough callbacks that they happen as part
of the render steps and to show why this
is useful I'm going to animate a box
just just a box and using this code so
I'm going to move that box forward one
pixel and then use requestanimationframe
to create a loop around this
and that's it that's all it does
so that's requestanimationframe but what
if we switched requestanimationframe for
set timer it looks like this now this
box is moving faster it's moving about
3.5 times faster and that means this
callback is being called more often and
that is not a good thing that's not a
good thing at all we saw earlier that
the render rendering can happen in
between tasks yes
but just because it can happen doesn't
mean it must in reality we can take a
task shall we render no it can't be
bothered yet go around the event loop
pick up another task shall we render now
now doesn't feel like the right time
many tasks can happen and before the
browser goes yeah actually next time we
will update the display and the browser
gets to decide when to do this and it
tries to be as efficient as possible the
render steps only happen if there's
something actually worth updating if
nothing's changed it won't bother like
if the browser tab is in the background
if it isn't visible it will never run
the render steps because there's there's
no point but also the majority of
screens update at a set frequency in
most cases that's 60 times a second some
screens go faster some screens go slower
but 60 Hertz is the most common so if we
changed page Styles like a thousand
times a second it's not going to run the
render steps a thousand times a second
it will synchronize itself with the
display and only render up to a
frequency the display is capable of
usually 60 times a second otherwise it
would be a waste of time like there's no
point rendering stuff the user will
never see but that's what set timeout is
doing here
it's moving faster because it's updating
the position of that box
more times than the user can see more
times and this display is capable of
showing us also so far we've been using
set timeout as this kind of shorthand
for a queue a task and it isn't really
because even though we've put zero
milliseconds for the callback it's more
like four point seven is what the
browser will use as a default the spec
says the browser can pick any number to
use but in the things I've tested it
seems to be about four point seven there
isn't assume a single method that's just
queues a task but we can kind of fake it
using message channels and so I ran out
there and if you're sensitive to
flashing images might be best to look
away now because that looks like this
the there's so many tasks happening that
it kind of just looks like the box is
getting a random position we're getting
a task every two hundred of a
millisecond so rendering can happen
between tasks but you can have many even
tens of thousands of tasks between
renderings okay
flashing image has gone now let's
imagine each of these is a frame that
it's displayed to the user so our
rendering steps they happen at the start
of each frame and that includes like
style calculation layout and paint not
necessarily all free every time depends
what actually needs updating but I like
this I like this is very this is very
neat and tidy this is this is a
beautiful picture tasks on the other
hand they couldn't give us stuff they
just kind of appear anywhere they fancy
that the event loop ensures that tasks
appear they happen in the right order
they happen in the order they were cute
but in terms of timing within a frame
there is no kind of ordering here at all
and we saw this with our set timer we
were getting four per frame three or
four per frame and that means that
three-quarters of those callbacks were
wasted effort in terms of rendering alt
animation libraries used to do something
like this where they were trying to use
a millisecond value that's going to give
them roughly 60 callbacks per second and
they're assuming a lot about the screen
they're they're assuming a screen 60
Hertz but that was the common case so it
kind of worked it eliminated some of the
duplicate effort unfortunately it was a
massive hack because the set timeout was
not designed for animation and it really
shows like due to inaccuracies you can
end up with drift so what's happened
here is we've we're doing nothing in one
frame and then in the next frame we're
doing twice the amount of work and that
is a visual jank to user it doesn't look
great also if one of your tasks runs
long you can end up moving the render
steps around because it's all running on
the same thread and you're sort of
disturbing there that lovely routine
that they have if we use
requestanimationframe rather than set
timeout it would look a lot more like
this I'm all neat and tidy all nice and
ordered everything is within the timing
of the frame even
longer tasks here when I see performance
traces like this this makes me happy
this is showing a good user experience
makes me feel very calm
you can't avoid tasks completely of
course because things like click events
they're going to be delivered to you in
the task and generally you want to
respond to those as soon as possible
fair enough but if you have things like
timers or you have stuff coming from the
network
I really recommend using
requestanimationframe to batch that work
together especially if you already have
animations running because you can save
yourself a lot of duplicate work and I
treat tasks like I treat people who
drink fizzy water like I acknowledge
that they exist but I keep our
interaction to a minimum because I do
not trust them at all I mean I would
consider myself an empathetic person but
I have limits like I think soda water is
totally disgusting and I cannot think of
a way that a human being could drink
fizzy water without gagging or being
sick or passing out or something so
people when I say someone who does drink
fizzy water I think there must be
something there must be something else
going on with them I maintain a Twitter
list of people who drink fizzy water
it's not a creepy thing I just I just
wanna make sure I know what they're up
to and what they're doing but when I
find the link between B's people and
Briggs it and Donald Trump I am blowing
the case wide open taking him straight
to the FBI and it pains me to tell you
this J's conf but this conspiracy goes
straight to the top I saw him in airport
drinking fizzy water every now and then
someone else a toons like over Jake you
drink diet coke and I think you'll find
the main ingredient is fizzy water ha ha
ha ha no that's different that's
completely different like the main
ingredient of air is nitrogen right but
you would still die if that's all you
breathed so it's more like that you
cannot survive on just fizzy water what
was I talking about
requestanimationframe right there's one
more detail I want to get to and this is
something that caught catches a lawyer
developers out it caught me out
requestanimationframe it comes before
for processing CSS and before painting
so code like this might seem expensive
like we're showing and hiding a box many
many times but this is actually really
cheap like javascript will always run to
completion before rendering happens so
while you're doing this the browser just
sits back and it lets you have your fun
changing a value and it doesn't really
think about it in terms of CSS at all
and then at the end when it actually
comes around to the render steps it goes
right what did you actually change in
the end and the only bit that matters is
this final line and this explains a
gotcha in CSS or at least something that
caught me out I had a thing right but I
wanted to animate from an exposition of
1000 to 500 and that sounds easy right
so I had my listener here I set the
exposition to 1000 I told it to
transition and I changed the value to
500 but that animate from 0 to 500 and
unselected come on browser that's not
asked you to do it's very clear I sent
1000 transition to 500 what I was like I
figured out that maybe I'm giving it too
much information they all at once and
it's the same reason we saw before like
the browser is not going to think about
it come just install one block of
JavaScript so it's going to ignore that
first transform value so ok fair enough
what I'll do then is I'm going to put
this the second day I'm gonna put
downside a requestanimationframe and now
it still animates from 0 to 500 and I
was like what is what is going on here
well I will tell you what's going on
because I finally figured it out the
user clicks on the button and that's a
task so we come around to here and this
is where we set the initial transform
and the transition fine we queue an
animation frame and we go around and
this is where we set the destination the
final transform value but the browser
doesn't think about CSS until this next
step over the purple block there this is
where it calculates the CSS so again it
totally misses the first value because
it hasn't thought about styles in
Queen those two things being set and
that's why to make this work you need to
use not one but two requests animation
frames and now this will animate from
1,000 to 500 incidentally there is a
hacky alternative for this you can use
something like get computed style and
just access one of the properties on it
and this force is the browser to perform
style calculation a lot earlier than it
naturally would but it makes the browser
take note of all of the things you set
up until that point so it's like oh okay
transform translate X 1000 that's a
thing that this element does be easily
careful with doing this because you can
end up forcing the browser's to do a lot
of extra style worked and it really
wants to it only really wants to do that
once per frame in reality the best way
to deal with this would be the animation
API as a web animation API because you
can just say I want it to go from here
to this other value and it all just
works but that's only in Chrome so it's
not really worth talking about right now
so if the position if
requestanimationframe within the render
step so if that was a surprise to you if
that was something you didn't know
already it's probably not your fault you
might have been misled by particular
implementations because agent Safari
they get this very wrong they put rafa
roundabout here most notably they put it
after paint and that's kind of annoying
because it means they if the user clicks
somewhere or something happens and you
want to batch that work you've been
using requestanimationframe edge in
Safari they will render before they get
to your callback so the users going to
see something and that means that you're
not going to see the actual changes you
make until the next frame along and
that's adding quite a significant delay
to things appearing on the screen and it
also makes it really difficult to batch
work together I hope this is something
ethics soon is there's been activity on
the books recently but the web standards
say it should be here and that's where
it is in Firefox and Chrome ok that's
enough about requestanimationframe I
want to take a look at microtasks
this is probably the least understood
part of the event we would say I
strongly associate microtasks with
promises but this is not where they
started back in the 1990's browsers
wanted to give developers await and
monitor Dom changes and the w3c went
okay also
that out for you and they gave us
mutation events so this is where I could
say okay I want to know when a node is
inserted into the body element and fine
excellent and you get a series of other
events as well but in practice this was
pretty problematically we take this bit
of code here what I'm doing is I'm
adding a hundred spans into the the body
element how many events would you expect
to receive as a result of this one event
one event for the whole operation nope
100 events one for each span yes but
also another hundred for this line here
when content is going into the actual
span a text node is going into this man
and because these events bubble this
simple piece of code is going to land
you with 200 events and because of this
like relatively simple Dom modifications
ended up treating triggering thousands
of events and if you were doing like a
tiny bit of work in these listeners that
quickly became a big bit of work and it
was a performance disaster what we
really wanted was a way to sort of hear
about a batch of this work it's similar
to what we saw with styles before we
want the browser to kind of sit back let
us do some stuff and then a convenient
point say some stuff changed it here is
a kind of an event or something to
represent all of those changes we won't
hear about it once not 200 times and the
answer became mutation observers and
they created a new queue called
microtasks a lot of documentation I read
about microtasks
suggests that it happens like I don't
know every turn in the event loop or it
happens after a task or something like
that and it is kind of true there is a
single place on the event loop where
micro tasks happen but that is not where
you'll generally encounter it they also
happen whenever the Java scripts every
whenever JavaScript finishes executing
yeah that means that the JavaScript
stack has gone from having stuff in it
to having no stuff in it and that's
where we run micro tasks so you can end
up with Microsoft's happening halfway
through a task you can have happen we
can have micro tasks in the render steps
as part of request animation frames kind
of anywhere anywhere javascript can run
so that means this java script will run
to completion adding a hundred spans and
their contents javascript finishes
executing and we get our mutation
observer callback
promis has made use of them as well so
here we queue a micro task and then log
yo JavaScript is finished executing so
we go for the micro tasks and we log hey
and that means when the promised
callback is executing you were
guaranteed that no other JavaScript is
midway through at the time the promised
callback is right at the bottom of the
stack and that's why promises use micro
tasks but what happens if we create a
loop using micro tasks bit like we did
was set timeout before same demo again
click the button and it blocks rendering
it blocks the tap in the same way a
plain while loop did very different from
set timeout before so promise callbacks
are async fine but what does async
actually mean I mean all it means is
that they happen after synchronously
executing code so that's why we get yo
before Hey but just being async doesn't
mean it must yield to rendering doesn't
mean it must yield to any particular
part of the event loop we've looked at
three different queues so far we looked
at task queues animation callback queues
which is where requestanimationframe
callbacks happen and now we're looking
at micro tasks and just to make your
lives a little bit easier
they all are processed very subtly
differently like we're seeing with task
queues we take one item and we take one
item only and if another item is cute it
just goes to the end of the queue fine
animation callbacks they happen until
completion except ones that were queued
while we were processing animation
callbacks
they are deferred to the next frame
micro tasks on the other hand they are
processed to completion including any
additional acute items so if you were
adding items to the queue as quickly as
you're processing them you are
processing micro tasks forever the event
loop cannot continue until that Hugh has
completely emptied and that is why it
locks rendering I sorry I get I get
really excited about this stuff I hope I
hope other people are excited about this
as I am thanks thank you thanks one
person excellent do I used to have a
real job right like many of you did this
stuff like that sort of speaking the
stand
work the creating slides it's used to be
my hobby but then my hobby became my job
and now I have no hobbies I'm a boring
person now and I think didn't I didn't
actually notice when this happened like
genuinely doing the first time I noticed
I went for an eye test and the optician
just making small talk asked and and
what are your hobbies
when did this happen like I said I
stressed so I I got a bit like oh I
can't I can't say nothing who says
nothing so I totally true I panicked and
I said I play the piano I don't play the
piano and I stressed even more cuz I
fought like she was going to say oh well
that's great
we don't need to use the letters chart
then it's some sheet music can you read
me the first five bars what chord is
this thankfully she didn't but yeah my
optician now thinks I'm a pianist that
was great
I don't go back to the opticians anymore
I'm terrified of like more piano chat I
don't know how I survive in the real
world right I think you're ready for
this next one occasionally I run little
JavaScript quizzes maybe that's my hobby
nope that's work too never mind yes
we're a little JavaScript quizzes and
this is my favorite question so I've got
a button an onclick I resolved a promise
and then log something but I have to
event listeners on the same element
doing the same thing so if the user
clicks a button what happens in which
order of things locked well our first
listener executes great so that's on the
JavaScript stack Q is a micro task and
then we get to the next line where we
log listen to what and that's the first
answer most folks agree on that bit put
what next and I run a Twitter poll on
this last week I've been speaking to a
few of you a few of you saw it most
people would say the next thing logged
is listener - that's 63 percent 5% of
people think nan is just logs and then
infinity that is not the answer but fair
enough to that five percent of people
but yes we've got 63 percent and
listening to is the wrong answer this is
real gotcha with script but if you
thought it was listening to then you're
in very good company so don't worry
about it our listener has finished so
we've gone from having something on the
JavaScript stack to nothing so it is
micro task time we are going to run that
promise and we are going to log micro
task 1 and there we go and then it's
time for the second listener and that
works the same so the order is listener
one micro task one listener two micro
task - but that's if the user clicks the
button what if the button is clicked
using javascript oh yes it's different
for starters our script is on the stack
we call click and that synchronously
dispatches the events so we start with
listener one great week you a micro task
and we log listener one and now it's
micro task time no no it is not micro
test time we can't run micro tasks this
is where it's different because our
JavaScript stack is not empty button doc
click has not returned yet so we move on
to listener to work you another micro
task and now we log listener to and this
is where it diverges and now our
listener is done in fact all our
listeners are done button dot click
returns our JavaScript stack tech
empties and now we can process those
micro tasks and they happen in order and
this has real-world implications they so
beware if you're using like promises in
this way you're using if you're using
automated tests as well because
automated tests if they're clicking
things on the page they're likely to be
using javascript to do it and that can
change the behavior of your code it's
also came up when we were looking at how
to add observables to the dom and how
they'd integrate with promises we hit
this question if we have a promise that
represents the the next click of a
particular link it's just this little
bit of code here can someone use that
promise and still call event dot prevent
default promises our async so have we
missed our chance to prevent the default
here turns out no it's fine it's totally
fine this works this just works unless
again the user clicks the link of some
cold clicks the link using javascript
and isn't the final puzzle of the talks
and over running a little bit to figure
this out we actually need to take a look
at the spec
so this is a very rough description of
how the spec for clicking a link works
but we start by creating an event object
and then for every listener we have we
invoke that listener with the event
object and then we take a look at has
that event object cancelled flag being
set if it's been set then we're not
going to follow the hyperlink but if
it's unset we will follow the hyperlink
when you call event dot prevent default
it sets this cancel flag on the event
object so if the user clicks a link
that's fine our micro tasks happen here
after each callback because that's where
the JavaScript stack empties but when we
call click with JavaScript it's just
going to call out to our processor link
click algorithm and it only returns once
that algorithm is complete so that
JavaScript stack never empties during
this algorithm so our micro tasks can't
happen so it hits this step free where
it looks at the event object and even if
you've got loads of promises trying to
call like prevent default it's too late
it's going to follow that hyperlink and
then sometime later those promise
callbacks happen but you've missed the
boat you've missed a point where you can
actually cancel that event so remember
that micro tasks they you know they
behave quite differently depending on
the JavaScript stack ok so that 34
minutes that was a massive brain dump of
everything I know about the event loop
and the various steps and various cues I
have found that knowing this stuff like
it prevents that case where you kind of
got a bit of code that's not doing what
you want so you just wrap it in a set
timeout and now it kind of works
sometimes knowing the stuff kind of
helps avoid that it helps me avoid jank
by getting stuff running on the correct
part of the event loop as well and I
hope I managed to explain this stuff in
a way that is helpful to you too like I
said I'm a stressful person so as a
result of this I'm now going to go and
collapse in a pile but you've been a
great audience
thank you very much chase
you